he's been on the show uh in person
before rocking some great usfl gear
about one of his
previous books on the subject of the
usfl his latest
tome is called three-ring circus kobe
shack phil in the crazy years of the
lakers dynasty
pleased to have jeff crowman here on the
show how are you jeffrey
i was thinking when i heard you talking
about kyrie i was trying to think who's
the equivalent of my boyhood
of kyrie irving and i the name i kept
coming to was orlando woolwich
which is your team gets orlando warriors
and you're like man we are set we got
orlando orange
right and then about two weeks in you're
like maybe
maybe we can get a second and a and a
bench player for him well
did orlando will ridge ever claim the
earth was flat as well i mean like um
you know i honestly i i want to keep i
want to like kyrie irving a lot
my kid my kids love him you know and
um this is just it's just weird it's
it's like he can't stick to a narrative
almost like here almost it's bad when
you're
it's bad when you're a lifelong nets fan
and i grew up loving the nets and you're
thinking
where's where's the sanity of derek
coleman when we need it
[Laughter]
well put as you can as you only can
alright so let's get into your book here
three-ring circus kobe shack phil
and the crazy years of the lakers
dynasty um
what did you glean that you didn't know
going in jeff
i mean i i think the thing i didn't
realize
the thing that really caught me was the
0304 season which is the last season
they were together
which i just found to be one of the most
fascinating seasons in any team's ever
gone through if you look at it
um malone and payton join the team
they have this quote unquote super team
they're going to dominate the league
but shaq reports out of shape the whole
year he's miserable because he wants a
contract extension jerry buss won't go
near it
phil jackson doesn't know whether he's
coming or going he's tired of coaching
kobe bryant
kobe is planning on leaving for the
clippers and is pretty steadfast
at the end of this year he's going to
sign with the clippers meanwhile he's
flying in and out of evil colorado
facing a potential of 20 years in prison
and he's mad at the lakers because of
the quality of the plane they have him
flying
the whole season is just a mess they
make the nba finals against detroit
and they lose in five games and and
kobe lead you know they have a team
party after game five and kobe goes up
to kareem brush
and kareem russ thinks everything's
great they're going to come back the
next year and kobe says there's no way
i'm playing with that mother effer again
he's referring to shaq and just the
whole year i've never
it's amazing they made the mba finals
it's one of the most fascinating single
seasons
of just train wreck after train wreck in
the history of uh at least my history of
writing about well i mean
you know you could you could make the
case that you know your book and
the era of that we're discussing
is what would you say the sequel to the
last dance in a way right i mean
that phil um we just saw what phil did
with chicago and all the craziness there
um
and we saw a 10-part documentary on that
and now here he is
uh moving to los angeles with um
what one would clearly say the uh the
heir
to air jordan and kobe with shaq and you
just basically described that
i mean phil it's it's amazing
any of his teams with everything that
was going on despite the remarkable
talent
was able to pull it off i guess would he
be the through line
in there and that jeff yeah i think so
i also i it's really interesting people
say you know they always get the wow he
had so much talent he had to win blah
blah blah
the thing about chicago the pecking
order was always really clear
like pippin was never trying to be
jordan it was not part of the plan it
wasn't like pippin was plotting
you know i should be getting more
touches i'm i'm better at this guy
in la i mean from the very beginning
kobe
and this is kind of what made him great
and brought a lot of his greatness as he
was
i'm better i i should be the number one
guy i should be the no more guy
and when you're a coach when phil
jackson showed up in la
in 99 he made it very clear we're gonna
run this offensive triangle here's text
winner he's the
brain child behind it it's got to go
through shaq it's gonna go through shaq
and kobe you're the number two guy
and um kobe are such a brilliant talent
that ended up they won
back to back to backs but he never
really fully bought into this idea that
i'm the number two and he's number one
and i just think
that phil was able to get so much out of
that team with that level of sort of
dysfunction
um it's pretty freaking amazing actually
it's pretty freaking amazing is one way
to put it
um and so we all know that there was um
a coming together between kobe and shaq
um later in life and
with kobe's life getting cut short we
know it was about a year or two before
all of that that they did get together
does that
surprise you based on you uh digging so
deep into
uh a time where uh so many feelings and
emotions were raw
jeff yeah i would say no because i i
just think
i thought about this a lot the book was
done before kobe died
and i was just thinking like who you are
at 25 who any of us are 25
is not who we are when we're in his case
41
and the same goes for sack and i
actually think i've been thinking about
a lot
when you think about kobe you think
about shaq when you think about shaq you
think about kobe
and you know like hall and oates they
don't get along well together they don't
go out together they don't travel
together they don't frequent together
they show up at the show they play the
show and they leave
and but they still have that bond that
eternal bond
i feel like shaq and kobe there's just
an eternal bond and when kobe died
for shaq he was just losing this person
who who you are attached to and who you
did so much with
and he's never going to be your best
friend but you have this history with
him that's really really profound
i think you saw that just hit him and
over overwhelm him
when he learned of kobe's death just
that they had this shared
bond that was really rocky and really
turbulent but produced some amazing
memories for a lot of people
three-ring circus is jeff pullman's
latest book about the kobe shack phil
crazy years of the lakers dynasty and so
you've written about
this dynasty you've written about the
cowboys dynasty
the boys will be boys the glory days and
party nights of the cowboys dynasty
you've written about showtime so you've
also written about the usfl
barry bonds jeff what have you learned
about team chemistry
what what what can you say about the
concept of
locker rooms in total disarray but
talent wins through
in other spots where you know you've
written about the mets too
where talent is great but it just can't
get through locker room disarray and cam
what have you learned about chemistry
throughout all of your years of
reporting
jeff i just think it's overrated
i really do i i do i think there was a
great book by joan ryan earlier this
year about the importance of team
chemistry and it was great it was a
great read
and i just don't see it i just think at
the end of the day
they did this was not a team with great
chemistry but they had two of the five
best players on the court
always you know and they they had these
role players who fit their slots really
well and it's not like everyone was
going out to dinner after games
it's not like they were all buddy buddy
i mean shaq and kobe they were not
friends
at all they were teammates and
co-workers but they were so good and if
you don't have good team chemistry but
you have a really good leader
who can who can sort of task focus you
and make sure when the time comes what
you are doing is is very
precise you're going to win a lot of
games so i just think
i mean i remember with when i was
writing about baseball barry bonds and
jeff kent were teammates and everyone
wanted to do the story of how they're
really starting to understand each other
those two guys hated each other they
tried to say five words to each other in
the course of a season
unless it was fu but they were really
good
so i just think at the end of the day
ultimately if you're really really good
and you have a decent coach keeping
things in order or dusty baker or phil
jackson
or davey johnson or jimmy johnson
you're gonna probably your your odds of
success are good even if you don't get
along that well so then how do you
explain the clippers of this year then
jeff right i mean i'm not saying it's a
it's a fail-proof vibe
again paul george's statement after it's
all over saying that
you know uh they just didn't spend
enough time together even though they
were just quarantined for six to eight
weeks in
a way that he uh in in very meaningful
and moving language talking about the
depression of the bubble that they
hadn't spent enough time together and
and and they have kawhi and they have
paul george and they've got two
sixth men of the year and a coach who's
won it all before and
and they don't even get to the
conference finals right i mean like
he he was kind of blaming team chemistry
in a way
yeah i i do think um i'm not just using
as an excuse to defend my argument i do
think the weirdness of the bubble
and covid and everything throws a little
x factor in that's hard to measure
uh and i also think denver was a really
good team like i do think in the midst
of all that
people sort of forgot that denver was
really good right like really good
and it's sort of like everyone was
looking especially out here in southern
california everyone's looking for these
excuses and
how could they let this happen well
maybe denver's is better to a certain
degree i mean they were really really
good
um and i do think i just think being in
this bubble and being in this world
right now is a really depressing place
to be
and maybe i mean i guess in some
circumstances team chemistry is
important if you're all living through
hell what reaction a few more minutes
left with jeff perlman here
uh on the rich eisen show three rings
circus is his latest book
kobe shack phil on the crazy years of
the laker dynasty what's been the
reaction from uh the kobe lovers out
there
about you uh covering uh a part of his
life that i think they would like to
forget
what's been that so i was braced i was
braced for
it to be really really bad and my my
cousin read the book a few weeks ago and
he said man this is gonna be rough
i've gotten three negative tweets and
while those three negative tweets
all from anonymous people were quite
wounding overall it hasn't i've been
i feel like because people knew who kobe
was like when i wrote i wrote a walter
payton biography
and the backlash initially was really
fierce but in chicago
walter payton was just strictly deified
and i do feel like
eagle colorado for example everyone saw
that happen everyone watched it happen
you know the the court case and
everything going on
even his difficulty was shaq that's not
a secret people knew that he could be
ornery and difficult and rough as a
young player
so i just feel like the main reaction
i've gotten i'm not making this up i
already swear like the main reaction has
been
you know you wrote it honestly it's not
surprising
but you were fair so that's that's kind
of all you can hope for
okay and when it's all said and done do
you think we're going to write about
lebron in the same way of being a laker
great
when it's all said and done jeff not in
the same way
do you i don't think do you think so no
i just think that you know uh we're
gonna i think we're three more games
away from seeing him get one
uh i don't think anthony davis is going
anywhere i think that they've got a
general manager who definitely got the
pieces right this non-playing season
i think the coach getting the win here
is gonna earn frank vogel
more uh respect uh i think that when
fans are let back into
staples it's gonna be must-see stuff
uh i think that lebron is not done after
this year by any stretch of the
imagination
um and i think that he's gonna have
banners plural
up in that staples center and that's the
thing that i don't think he'll ever be
you know obviously the same level of
kobe but we will be talking about
showtime era and this era that you've
written about and maybe right now
i i do think so jeff i could see i think
lebron will go down to laker history
in the way will chamberlain does we sort
of think of him as another team first
but he goes down we i know he'll
obviously win more than wilted with it
with lakers
but he'll go down as a as a very special
player he'll have his number retired
but i do think at the end of the day
kobe's a laker even shaq is really a
laker
and i think lebron you think is a
cleveland guy who had some really great
years in la
what's next for you what do you want to
what are you curious about jeff what
else
i'm doing a bo jackson biography okay
now we're talking jeff okay uh are you
talking about
are you in contact i talked to him once
for a half hour he he has not been the
most cooperative but he's been he's been
very nice
so it's he's not he's a uh he's a very
guarded human being
he's a really nice guy but very guarded
so what do you want to what are you
looking f what are you looking at what
are you what are you curious about what
are you curious about
i just think i just think the mythology
of that guy is ridiculous
and i've interviewed about 250 300
people so far
and you just get over and over again
i'm going to tell you something and
you're not going to believe it like you
hear that all the time i'm going to tell
you something and you're not going to
believe it but i swear to god it's true
i'm going to tell you he hit a home run
that went 700 feet i know you don't
believe me
he was standing i was with bo he was
standing in a pool
and he jumped flat-footed waist deep out
of the pool i know you're not gonna
believe me
but it's true like over and over again
and i freaking loved
the book wouldn't be nearly as
interesting if he played 12 years in the
nfl and was marcus allen or played
15 years in major league baseball became
kirk gibson like the mythology is the
thing there
have you spoken to dion about him yet no
not yet oh you have to
you i mean cause you you want to talk
about the arrows
right of baseball and football and
being able to do remarkable things on on
either field um and at the same time
you know two sports stars i mean dion
i i know that dion doesn't have the same
mythology in baseball
as bo jackson did but dion could have
been the world series mvp had the braves
beaten the blue jays
in the year that the blue jays won uh
basically just looked those look those
figures up
and then in terms of being able to do
spectacular things
on a football field as well as know the
guy
and be able to speak about the
difficulty of doing these things at once
at the same time
with everybody staring at you and having
promotional campaigns built around you
i think he'd be an excellent interview
for you jeff oh i agree there's also an
amazing video
of beau's senior year at auburn and dion
coming in to make the tackle
and beau just tossing him aside
well that's not dion's forte i mean like
like i mean yeah
i mean of all the things that we're
talking about dion's mythology i don't
think tackling has ever been one of them
but watch jackson city the best tackling
team in all of college football
because he's getting ready to bring all
that hey jeff congrats on the book let's
uh let's keep chatting this is uh this
is great as
as expected you take care of yourself
all right thanks for watching i
appreciate it that's jeff perlman at
jeff perlman on twitter
three-ring circus kobe shackville
and the crazy years of the lakers
dynasty hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here